et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
avec faouzi charfi secrétaire général du
syndicat des médecins spécialistes
faouzi charfi merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors pourquoi
cet événement cette mort accidentelle de
l'un de vos confrères a entraîné la
révolte de la profession bonjour je
voudrais présenter je suis membre du
bureau exécutif du syndicat des médecins
spécialistes de libre pratique et moi
l'intervention aujourd'hui s'inscrit
dans le cadre d'une action unitaire de
tout le corps médical public et privé
face à la dégradation sans cesse
croissante du système sanitaire
tunisiens notamment au niveau des
hôpitaux publics est la goutte qui a
fait déborder le vase a été cet accident
tragique
le décès tragique de notre jeune
confrère résidents choisi de 26 ans à
l'hôpital régional de saint do ba et qui
est mort le à la suite d'une chute
mortelle dans un ascenseur défectueux et
aujourd'hui la disparition le docteur
badreddine à lui a permis d'unifier tous
le corps médical et tout le corps
sanitaires pour demander d'un seul
tenant
lang d'engager immédiatement les
réformes du système sanitaire que nous
avons appelée de nos voeux depuis une
décennie pratiquement il y actuellement
beaucoup de laisser aller au niveau des
hôpitaux
il y à une situation du fait accompli
il ya un problème de gouvernance nouveau
didot plutôt d'un problème de corruption
de petites et de grandes cochon et il y
a actuellement un problème de
financement de la santé en tunisie tous
ces problèmes mais sur la table c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'a reconnu finalement le
ministre de la santé je vais le site et
après avoir évité visité l'hôpital de
jean do ba ou la whey les cédez votre
confrère le ministre de la santé a dit
je cite le secteur paie la facture de
choix erronés cumulé depuis des années
il y a un manque d'équipements dans tous
les hôpitaux la fota qui finalement ne
crois que nous n'en sommes plus au stade
des constats ces constats ont été faits
par les différents ministres
qui sont passés à la tête de ces
ministères et vous savez que nous sommes
en train actuellement de vivre une
transition démocratique est quelque peu
chaotique en tunisie et que le nombre la
multiplication des ministres à la tête
du ministère de la santé a fait que
aucun ministre n'a eu le temps d'établir
et de mettre en place un programme clair
d'autant que les élections vont pas
amener des gouvernements avec une
stratégie claire en matière de santé et
aujourd'hui il ne s'agit plus de faire
un constat il s'agit de passer aux actes
nous savons où les problèmes il ya tout
un travail qui a été fait un énorme
travail qui a été fait d'audit au niveau
du système de santé tunisien qui est un
excellent système de santé avec une
excellente qualité de médecin tunisien
des vous en août l'europe en sait
quelque chose
le moyen-orient c'est quelque chose que
nous sommes confrontés à une vague
d'immigration de l'autre jeune médecin
vers ce pays là et ils sont pris et
immédiatement dans des structures
sanitaires de très grande qualité est
donc aujourd'hui nous demandons le
passage à l'acte reste on mettra autour
d'une table discutons des problèmes
réels la santé du financement de la
santé qu'elles courent voulons être pour
la santé du tunisien le problème de
gouvernance et les problèmes de
corruption et de savoir comment
améliorer l'existant parce que 80 % les
tunisiens ce soit dans l'hôpital public
sans hôpital public
il n'y a pas ce secteur privé et le
public reste réservoir de la formation
et la structure à laquelle s'adresse le
maximum de personnes
alors aujourd'hui aujourd'hui notre
syndicat demande qu'il y ait un
établissement dès que les
responsabilités soient établies il nous
considérons que le premier responsable
reste l'oeuvre reste le ministre de la
santé
et c'est dans ce sens que nous avons
demandé à ce que le ministre de la santé
actuelle présente sa démission
horatio et une responsabilité politique
et morale de cet accident tragique
alors on arrive au terme de cette
édition néanmoins qu'elle en quelques
mots une nouvelle manifestation attendue
donc aujourd'hui vous avez le sentiment
d'être écoutés entendus en tout cas en
tout cas aujourd'hui il y à une grève
nationale du corps médical entier public
privé en tunisie
la dernière grève nationale date d'il ya
quelques années
nous allons continuer à mobiliser ce ne
sera pas encore une manifestation où une
marche solidaire en vain il faudra
absolument que les autorités nous
entende et nous demandons la création
d'une instance supérieure de la santé
dans laquelle on puisse discuter des
problèmes de la santé la santé la
tunisie d'après l'indépendance a été
fondée sur l'éducation et la santé
ce secteur est en train de l'est est en
danger et il s'agit aujourd'hui d'un
sauvetage n'est entrepris de sauvetage
du secteur de santé qui reste un des
moteurs économiques
un des moteurs de la pièce social est un
moteur du bien-être en tunisie merci
beaucoup
faouzi charfi d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général du syndicat des
médecins spéciale